The number of columns in each odd row will be two, and in each even
row will be one. This is because the width is 1,900. So if we start from
all the way on the edge, we can fit 800 plus another 800 is 1,600, but
not another 800 which would give us 2,400. So that calculation was 1900
over 800, and then we lost the decimal. In the even
row, we had to subtract 400 from 1,900, because
we can't use these first 400 meters. Then we
can fit 800, and at this point we're at
1,200, and if we add another 800, we would be
at 2,000, but that's more than 1,900, so that
wouldn't fit. So that calculation was 1,900, minus 400 over
800 and then we dropped the decimal. Let's write
an equation for this. Write it down and skip if
you know the rest. To calculate the number of columns per odd row, we calculated
the width, which was 1,900 divided by the diameter, which was 800.
And then dropped the decimal. To calculate the number of columns per even row,
we started with the width, subtracted the
radius, or 400. Divided by the diameter,
and then again, tossed the decimal. Write
this down. You're going to want it for later.